[Musique]
non
ensemble
douleur
avec de la magnésie sterling
s'est arrêté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi non
comme les secondes ensemble
ensuite
[Musique]
L'Uruguay dans votre monde
ce n'est pas juste deux
[Musique]
à présent
avec tout ça me tue
[Musique]
regarde bien
Oui je lis
[Applaudissements]
comme vous l'avez dit d'un est comme vous
avec le sol après le nobel
moto2
comme les humains du monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu n'as pas que 20 ans
[Musique]
formule moncada
sauf le bois ses systèmes
cette chose n'est pas renversée qui me libère
discours de pressions
[Musique]
et elle
ré
l'a gardée ici plans de titre
quand il a lu, ils ont brûlé ou si vous lisez
[Musique]
tu es vaincu aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs
de tout
indiquer
la cure
[Musique]
Oui
Oh
[Musique]
le soleil
j'ai fait
[Musique]
je le mule
ton numéro
jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]